brasilia 13 lazio liguri che siamo di
voi minecraft parkour col mio amico
pietro sta diventando sempre più
difficile perché siamo intorno al bello
denti e le cose complicano sempre
ricordate che dobbiamo arriva fino al
100 quindi questa cosa sara
improponibile però vabbè buona visione
ragazzi carpet uguale slide block è
invece il tappeto c'è lo slide block
madonna che bello sto livello
ok no guarda così devi fargli bekele 2
slime quindi ho lasciato i siti dove al
lavoro che abbiamo fatto insieme a
meredith ordinatissimi mai da che parte
po più pratico aspetta che qua si provi
inseguo madonna e non li odio questi di
olio perché devi tirare la testata
subito è una volta che lei tirata devi
andare avanti
una donna madonna ma deve qua inchieste
e giusto scendere qui sotto però io gli
ho fatto per me è giusto non è giusto
che ci ha vinto in toto 17 sono campioni
d'italia ma è bellissimo questo di
viterbo ti prego che il calcio è questo
male divenire amiche perché troppo bello
quello dopo
no sto cadendo domati ma c'è un buco ma
amiche che succede no ho schiacciato il
tasto e sei venuto qua
mara ci credo bassi tassi sono bancati
nega tutto ma sono pagati già vastissimo
in alto livello grazie la braci life ha
fatto un cazzo
vabbè
bra bravo tutto con le tue forze giusto
secondo me equa e non lo so che poi
vanno di qua divisori cartelline tv
cadono le distanze ma non per sfortuna
perché se già così è un casino
immaginate che c'è una parte c'e l'edera
scusa quando le collegherà no non ci
credo
no no c'è un pungente datolo e ma non
può ad un punto
io l'ho fatto ok nomiche porco del
demonio maledetto buono nice nice nave
le scale sono facili tranne questo odio
perfetto fortissimo mamma fortissimo
mamma mia che giocatore non fare niente
per favore fammi capire dove si va a
ragazze negativa vai vai ecco quella
dritto fate finta e poi è finita finché
titoli per niente adesso vai su questo
piccolo che è una cagata ricorda no
mannaggia guardandola si merita tutto un
momento di infarto mamma mia sarebbe
stato solo di server dicevo tantissimo
si d isère nel diserbo i termini di
server
esatto o mamma mi cos'è che non cast ai
capelli
tuttavia sola ma ho capito è mai
problemi dopo però non capisco qua e qua
di andare per forza di fare
qua devi fare simmi a fare questa scusa
stavo per annunciarti dai crociati 6
tracciato
questo cosa stai dicendo micro è uguale
aspettati procedere a toccare niente non
puoi farlo perché non come cachi hai
fatto allora come fa quello che i botti
spiego è è veramente stupido ma se non è
impossibile devi arrivare gia causato
esatto poi lasci primo secondo i primi
subito il il lo shift ragazzi dello
giuro da due ora eravamo fermi non
capivamo ma non sa come cachi fatta
questa roba che ci ho provato a michael
un possibile no ragazzi era incapibile
la cosa più di fiducia che abbiamo fatto
ed era una cagata perché non si capiva
ragazzi assurdo vi giuro vabbè dai bel
ali g g l'ex top ma attenzione a non
cadere qua che tifa riformato lo so per
cadere soli
no no non andare e dove dove lo aspetta
ma c'è un punto prima tomic
c'è un punto prima prima sexy no non lo
so
no non lo so non è detto ma questa cosa
sono arrivati lo so non si capisce
bisogna arrivare praticamente la bisogna
saltare prima su questo ok madron
ok ok ok ok crucciato qua e poi ha
finito
credo siano fatte e nell'acqua e varie
penso ai miei beni bravo però c'è un
bravo crociato bravo pensa che quando
cioè non cadere in questo tempo finito
sono i soprannomi definito e non si
capisce mamma mi valore che come faremo
a 19 18 ancora siamo non è finita e
occhio come un infinito ma non lo so
amiche non cadere di sotto che un
problema lo faccio per te questo no no
no cosa risaputa
c'è un blocco visivi non tutto il 6
agate mano è vallo a sapere tu come
cachi fatto se non lo sapevi io io ci ho
sperato perché ho visto che da tempo di
farne è vero che ritorna e ma magari ti
ammazza v
tu sei pazzo lui non avrei fatto lo
stesso dove let's golf
ok poi semplicissimo easy qualcuno o che
stavo capendo easy palco non lo faccio
ok però fatto primo fa vi saluto
tartarughe e fortissimo amico
l'esplosione che ha avuto ancora
concreta 6 saluto non saluto va bene va
bene ma mi ha aspettato una cagata cioè
gli spetta dormiamo no quando si fa di
questo studio secondo è un aborto
niente credo che però si apre qualche
con questo il 19 ma dai 19 una migliore
da un modernissimo non vedo una marzo
amiche
siamo in un livello minimi nier ravel in
una mini miniera minimi era miniera mi
era ce l'ho fatta ce l'ho fatta una
miniera
ok che male però sono vivo e fatto ci
posso credere
lei nomino qua fino qua qua allora la
vostra foto col petto la perfetta che
devo fare una roba incredibile proprio
esatto esatto è poi stato lo puoi fare
no no sei un uomo sei un nuovo altro
bene per morto sì molto no bellissimo ma
corre aspetta ma scusami madama ragazzi
ma io sto diventato un fenomeno non sarà
che cosa farmene risalente di me ma
scusami ma abbiamo fatto vivo nella mi
vedi niente non mi vede sono morto dimmi
cosa vuoi utili sale ed baird e
risalente era amico mio derisa lander
l'ho vista la leather effettivamente
lohan che pretendo allora questa è una
di pedibus e se posso dire uno dei punti
più difficili veramente cieco lei
veramente un casino perché la lettera ok
che c'è ma non è finita attenzione per
cadere di sotto anonimi lista che poi a
manolo noi e tenete finta 20
let's go slow fast ha solo fatto che ho
fatto qui faccio io arrivo con calma del
mio secondo da me matematica al mattino
davanti ma lo sapevo ha funzionato c'è
nessuna sorpresa passa dietro agli usa
ue check point che sono
ci mettiamo una vita che vedete uscivi
derisa lettere da qua oh di là
a questa napoli prima facendo come dai
avendo cosi finito anche dubbi perché mi
prese con la mente ho fatto ciao aspetta
che ma che figata
niente ci si questo devi farlo da gialli
sicuro ok
bello bello bello
venuto bello c'è merda è amico no è
amico si caduto ma dolce ho fatto solo
fatto ciò fatta 21 spettacoli amiche e
il momento è ma non ci sono tasti no
aspettando altro nodo certo come che
visto che non ci sia la noche una scala
qua che spiega non so a no perché da
sotto la fatto il parkour e allora sta
capirò di piano di conserva che bello
sul piano presenta affatto quale per cui
mi sa che cosa clicchiamo come cacchio
esco di qua dove l'unico demonio qua
sotto so quando sei sul 6
ecco adesso esci da qui riesce pesci se
riesci e ci si riesce
esci 3 a 10 i sessi ma che facciamo è un
ora che sto giovani capito invece che
non si può fare niente da sotto non c'è
nulla e no a me non penso che ben noti
c'è un passaggio segreto qua guarda non
vedo niente celava smetta o dio
ok ok no no si trovata ho fatto ciò
fatta io ma chi o più o meno quasi circa
va bene a prossimo va bene
[Musica]
nice perche no non ci credo non è vero
sono morte in un punto stupidissimo
mannaia a me proprio ok quindi to ride
forza non cadere
beh c'è un muro a loro che l'ho fatto
l'ho fatto quando ho avuto mingchao sei
un morto in blu e pietro morto ma sono
vivo io ce l'ho fatta
negli altri c'è qualcosa quale ok sto
uscendo non so dove adesso mandato
voluta la libreria perché pensa che fico
sempre desse fuoco la libreria ma no ma
scusami eh sì almeno andiamo avanti c'è
la stessa col muro perché quest'anno non
dietro libreria sono ok ok che cacchio
devo fare a c'è un'altra scala n'è una
che vi sta capendo cosa fare che non
capisco come cacchio si fa bravissimo
ok ma noi adesso di spazio quale spazio
a vado io fermati comoda che è io che ho
io chiusa
ok grazie così ok farà quindi secondo
che arriva amiche si 6 ho paura forse no
aspetta aspetta non capisco se devo fare
qua non come poi come il fatto come
solito ed verso sinistra per dossena
robben troppo attaccato al muro è per
l'aspetto atleta stata stretta viene qua
perché non capito cosa fare ok qui c'è
qui c'è qualcosa che guarda guarda qui
c'è una scala amiche la vista e neutri
per sbaglio io eh ma tv togli come
faccio lascio fatto ha giocato lo stesso
ho finito amico che non potrà più
luminose c'è ma se c'è un
il merito il pulsante alleanze della
stessa cercando non c'è dice no non c'è
ma forse c'è nel livello dopo che ci sei
e io sto capendo da un ora come arriva
perché allora aspetta qua eh
è strano perché gioca nel mese allora
guardare come scendo bene ho prese
d'acqua bravo amico non voglio più stare
con te quando guidò i centri maga strada
l'aspettativa che poi un bordello
perché qui c'è uno slide per non capisco
cosa devo fare ma devo fare questa cosa
che stavo facendo quindi lo slime è
diventato invece che una roba fattibile
in è stata una roba di disturbo cosa c'è
ma se non sicuri sia giusto così non ci
no non sono sicuro per niente vai vai
dritto dritto del suo dritto niente
tutto d'un fiato
il tutto in un piatto anno cazzo noioso
piatto per terra bravo bella mi piace
questa filosofia ma facendo di tutto
d'un fiato non è bene ok da pochi cacchi
devo farlo da lì quindi ha detto periodo
ai ruderi curano adesso a minchia nova
le ragazze aiuto
bravo amico vai rapaci ma perché mi devi
guardare che metti un botto di ansia yes
scala o quello dopo le tante 23 okabe
fantastico cia ora i denti ma c'è un
leone le porte non gradevole volevo
darti una scossa di vita mani che ha
illuso fortissimo mica lo so lo so
amiche quello che so fare bene grazie
ok prego intanto sto finendo quello dopo
ma come siete fin da ora dovrà però ci
ho provato per è stato che è stato bello
che ci stava riuscendo sul serio deve
entrare in questo pc di camino poi entra
nel camino buon natale braccia e oporto
di regalarmi sembra facile ma come
regalo di portare che fino a questo
livello perché non è facile
ok bellissimo che da quando ci sono più
di altri
poi che questo che mi viene benissimo
che ogni livello a tema e bellissima
storia è più tranquillo che lo fa no
però devi fare questo in alto di fare
sicuramente questa cosa di sicuro non lo
so non ne sono totalmente sicuro non è
stato un attimo mi sono circa tranquillo
che non è quindi ok veni veni vidi ok e
da lì un blocco bellissimo perfetto
perfetto è adesso questo ok ok non a
meno che mai avevano fatto con
nochalance mamma mia mi che ce l'ho
fatta solo forte madonna sono riuscito e
ci cuoce il tasto riesco gucher 00 pre
che allora questo sembra una cagata
ma ovviamente non lo sarà perché lo vedi
che c'e il tutto in un fiato ma mi sa
che sarà no perché di qua non si va di
qua non puoi andare su sti cosi di
metallo amiche di metallo di cos'è sta
roba
eccolo del land land amiche come proprio
di oggetto
cosa devo le vedere che cosa dell'ente
poi l'acqua scusa è dritto per dritto
dritto google non vedi che c'è il muro
no war
non ho capito te lo giuro ok
qua devo fare una roba yes pry mamma mia
è mosso caso o no no non puoi carriera
ma guarda i casi è stato applicato ai
cari vogliono rompere su youtube non sei
attivo il pulsante nostro mondo on my
friends a chi guarda
non c'è stata tirato su ok vai profonde
vai vai provare vai prendino e lo sto
per dire eccolo eccolo
mai che non avevano male che funziona
sta roba
quindi my boys costerà più di minecraft
parking day spero vi sia piaciuto
voi ragazzi mi piace ci vediamo nel
quarto episodio e iscrivetevi al canale
e come sempre bei ragazzi
[Musica]
ma